it's a miracle any movies ever get made
given anything can go wrong with
hundreds of people using dangerous
equipment while spending tens of
millions of dollars there are so many
variables that sometimes filmmakers
after call the whole thing off all
because someone did something dumb here
are some movies that got cancelled
because of an idiot mistake
Star Trek Planet of the Titans Star Trek
was cancelled after three seasons in
1969 but its popularity exploded in
syndicated reruns by 1977 the series was
set to hit the big screen with a film
called
Star Trek Planet of the Titans where the
enterprise and Captain Kirk would face
off against the Giants of Greek
mythology but just before filming was
set to begin the paramount president
Barry Diller cancelled the whole thing
for a really stupid reason Star Wars was
already scheduled to arrive in theaters
that year and he didn't think fans could
like sci-fi enough to support to space
their pics in the same year
way too totally completely mystery the
entire industry Barry Justice League
mortal long before Marvel crushed the
box office with Avengers Warner Brothers
was planning its own superhero team-up
in the form of Justice League mortal
which went into production in 2007 with
Mad Max fury road director George Miller
set to direct the film at a budget of
200 million dollars and had already
begun rehearsing with a cast that
included Armie Hammer as Batman Megan
Gayle as Wonder Woman and the rapper
common as Green Lantern just one problem
they forgot to actually finish writing
the script and before they could get
around to it the Writers Guild of
America went on strike by the time the
strike ended the actors had moved on to
other projects and the whole film had to
be scrapped whoops
nute in 2008 Pixar announced its later
films for the coming years and among
them was a movie called newts the plots
what happens when the last remaining
male and female blue footed newts on the
planet are forced together by science to
save the species and they can't stand
each other it was so far along in
production that picks our animators left
lilies direct referencing Newton Toy
Story 3 such as the newt crossing sign
on Andy's bedroom door but in 2011 Fox
Animation Studios released rear which
had almost the exact same plot only with
birds instead of lizards and which had
reportedly been in production since
around 2007 one year before newt was
announced Pixar panicked worried that
newt would be considered a ripoff and
counseled it's entirely strange they
didn't do that with ants on a bug's life
ok can we stop in humans it sure looks
like in humans which features Marvel
characters who are kind of like mutants
but also kind of from space would be the
next massive on screen team for Marvel
announced for a 2018 release the film
seemed to be built up from two entire
seasons worth of storylines on ABC's
Marvel's agents of shield but then
Inhumans was quietly dropped from the
schedule why there are a couple of
theories because of the disconnect
between Marvel's TV efforts and its
movie business Marvel Studios may not
have been happy at having the Inhumans
movies details dictated by a television
show with middling ratings meanwhile
rumor has it that Inhumans was the pet
project of Marvel CEO Ike Perlmutter and
when Poe matzo was ousted from his role
at Marvel Studios in favor of studio
President Kevin Feige bagi dumped the
film to stick it to his rival and pursue
his own vision instead namely Captain
Marvel
[Applause]
although when you think about it the
biggest mistake of all might have been
Marvel's selling the x-men movie rights
to Fox way back in the 1990s would never
have had to hear about the Inhumans
movie in the first place
a Revenge of the Nerds remake in 2006
Fox atomic began filming a modern-day
reboot of the classic 80s College movie
series Revenge of the Nerds at Emory
University in Atlanta and then school
officials actually read the script
he is actual footage from when Emma Roy
University's president finished looking
at the screenplay
anyway after that the college
immediately pulled out of the project
even though much of the movie had
already been filmed producers were
forced to complete the movie at tiny
Agnes Scott College when Fox atomic
honcho Peter rice saw how rinky-dink the
movie looked as a result he decided to
just scrap the entire thing who made the
bigger mistake Emma Roy for agreeing to
participate in the movie before reading
the script or Fox for actually caring
about production values on Revenge of
the Nerds two sequels to Terminator
Salvation in 2009 Terminator Salvation
earned 371 million dollars worldwide
thanks in part to the star power of
Christian Bale as a time-traveling robot
killing humanity saving John Connor two
sequels were planned except the house
lien company which produced the movie
went bankrupt even with all that revenue
through some kind of financial idiocy
they couldn't pay off the 39 million
dollars they owed the hedge fund
PacifiCorp in order to pay their debt
her listen auctioned off the rights to
terminator the winning bid twenty-nine
point five million dollars from
PacifiCorp nice exit strategy Dumb and
Dumber to here's a real what if way back
in 1998 South Park creators Trey Parker
and Matt Stone signed a 1.5 million
dollar deal with New Line Cinema to
write a prequel to the 1994 hit comedy
Dumb and Dumber it sounds like a match
made in heaven
so you're telling me there's a chance so
what was the idiot mistake turns out
Parker and stone didn't actually want to
do the project in the first place they
eventually gave the money back leading
newline to hire other writers for what
eventually turned out to be the universe
leap and 2003 prequel Dumb and Dumber
When Harry Met Lloyd hey I like that
movie The Adventures of fart man
Howard Stern first created his superhero
alter ego fart man back in 1981 and it
turned into a pre-internet meme of a
massively popular appearance at the 1992
MTV Video Music Awards it was such a hit
that New Line Cinema started production
on a feature film called The Adventures
of fart man which screenwriter jf Lawton
promised would be just as crude and lewd
as you'd expect from a Howard Stern
movie however when executives got wind
of what Lawton was planning they asked
him to tone it down and make it a
mainstream pg-13 film instead Stern
immediately quit in protest with a dumb
request and that was the end of fart man
oh well the Queen / freddie mercury
biopic cami lien Sasha Baron Cohen was
once set to play the legendary lead
singer of Queen Freddie Mercury who died
in 1991
it seemed like the perfect fit since
Cohen is not only a big fan he also
bears more than a passing resemblance to
mercury but Cohen backed out with the
project when he discovered that the
surviving members of Queen wanted the
second half of the film to focus not on
mercury but on how great the band has
continued to be since his death two more
fledged sequels eight years after Chevy
Chase last played smug and smarmy
reporter I am Fletch in 1989's Fletch
lives the franchise was set to make a
comeback thanks to filmmaker Kevin Smith
Smith wanted the film to focus on
Fletcher's daughter to be played by his
then girlfriend at Jamie Lauren Adams
verse after Smith and chase squabbled
over a plan to have chase reprise his
role as Fletch the entire project was
scrapped
apparently Chase had something birt'day
yeah there's nothing going on at the
Rotary Club I heard about this not to be
deterred Smith later convinced Miramax
to buy the rights to the franchise this
time for an origin prequel that would
star his buddy Jason Lee and wouldn't
involve Chase at all but Miramax didn't
think Lee was a big enough star and shut
the whole thing down
looks like Chase had the last laugh
[Laughter]
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and he was the
comment to let us know which of these
movies you most wish had been made
you
[Music]